Here the only solution is x equals positive 5. Nice solving if you found this
number. First we'll take our quadratic equation, and we'll subtract 15 from
both sides in order to set it equal to 0. So we'll have x squared minus 2x
minus 15 equals 0. Now we've factored this quadratic to give us the two factors
x minus 5 times x plus 3. Next, we said each factor equal to 0 and then we
solve for the values of x. So x can be positive 5 or x can be negative 3. When
considering these values for solutions, we want to think back to the original
equation. If we plug in a negative 3, in for x, then this argument would be
negative, an this one would be as well. Remember, we can't take the logarithm
of a negative number. So that means this solution is out. This is why the only
answer is x equals positive 5.